[Música]
justamente como lo estábamos diciendo
ahora vamos a continuar aquí en France
24 con
discúlpenme con directo a y por eso
Vamos hasta Estados Unidos porque mañana
se realiza en Georgia la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones de medio mandato para
definir Quién será el senador por ese
estado la contienda está entre El
republicano herschel Walker y el
demócrata Rafael Warner el control del
senado ya está en manos de los
demócratas con 50 escaños y el voto de
definición de la vicepresidenta camela
Harris que Define cuando hay empate sin
embargo ganar este asiento se ha
convertido en una importante cuestión
para Joe biden y su partido por eso ya
conectamos con Cristóbal Vázquez que
justamente se encuentra en el cierre de
campaña del candidato demócrata
Cristóbal Buenas noches En qué radica la
importancia de este escaño que sería el
número 51 para los demócratas
es importante por tres puntos especiales
el primero porque se deja de depender de
El senador demócrata Joe manche en este
senador ha sido la piedra en el zapato
para la administración de Joe biden en
el congreso porque ha atendido ha votado
en los proyectos importantes de el
presidente Joe biden a favor de los
republicanos entonces lograron voto más
lograr el voto 51 en la mayoría que ya
tienen los demócratas en el senado pues
les daría la independencia para no tener
que depender de este senador yo manching
por el estado de Virginia occidental
para poder aprobar sus proyectos o
investigaciones en el senado el segundo
punto que es bastante importante es que
pues teniendo en cuenta que la
diferencia actual es de 50 votos a favor
de los demócratas 50 a favor de los
republicanos de tener un voto más kamala
Harris dejaría de ser la que haga el
desempate en las votaciones
proyectos importantes en el senado Y
kamala entonces se podría dedicar a
hacer campañas su reelección Y por
último pues está el punto de que Georgia
pues definitivamente se convertiría en
un estado bisagra en un estado péndulo y
dejaría de ser un estado rojo bueno
Cristóbal y en estos momentos Cómo está
la imagen de cada candidato alguno
podría registrar realmente Una ventaja
abrumadora podríamos ver la ola Roja de
apoyo de la que hablaban los
republicanos en la primera vuelta y que
de hecho no ocurrió
no ocurrió y sin embargo Ninguno de los
candidatos tiene una ventaja abrumadora
precisamente por eso hay una segunda
ronda porque ninguno logró más del 50%
en la votación en la primera ronda pero
las encuestas de Fox de CNN de otras
encuestadoras importantes dicen que
Rafael World el candidato demócrata
tiene una ventaja promedio de cuatro
puntos han votado hasta ahora de forma
anticipada uno coma ocho millones de
habitantes de ciudadanos acá en Georgia
y la ventaja Pues sí es a favor de los
demócratas que de hecho han invertido 81
millones de dólares en campaña desde el
9 de noviembre Este es el doble de lo
que los republicanos han invertido Así
que los demócratas esperan que esta
inversión se vea reflejada en las urnas
mañana a partir de las siete de la
mañana